Roger Staubach was just named Cowboys
nominee for the salute to service award
presented by USAA also helping USA a
promote Veterans Day their campaign and
Rodger joins us now the former Heisman
winner and Super Bowl MVP Roger good to
talk to you again how are you today good
morning Dan okay good just get a little
chilly here in Dallas wait wait wait
what is chilly in Dallas Roger
well it's 40 degrees right now so that
it's getting chilly for us what's the
coldest weather you ever played in well
we played I think the one year we played
in in Minnesota and it was like I was
like 9 degrees or something but it
wasn't there wasn't windy so they you
know if you get you can play in the cold
or a biscuit was probably between 9 and
15 because but without the wind you get
that windchill factor that's uh that's
really a downer when it's a cold day and
then he got a windy day like they had at
the Ice Bowl it was minus 13 degrees
with the wind chill factor I think it
was minus 40 that no yeah was that was
that 1975 when the Cowboys went up there
in the plows was that the game you're
talking about
no the Ice Bowl was I was actually still
I was in the Navy I was listening to the
the Ice Bowl the Cowboys were playing
Green Bay no I was talking about the
coldest game you played in yeah yeah
yeah well we played it it would I think
the 71 was a little colder we played
them in the in the playoffs and then 75
we had the Hail Mary pass day was not it
was probably in the 20s that day so
that's not bad at all can you clear that
up the Hail Mary you get a lot of credit
for you know coining that phrase or
using that did you okay dan I am really
proud of that credit because that the
term was not used in 1975
you know the balm the alley-oop and all
the you know the big plays but we were
playing the Vikings it was a we law on
1414 to 10
we got the ball back at the end of the
game and and we went down and and Drew
Pearson made this great catch now the
Viking fans say the drew pushed off but
you see the film it looks like Nate
Wright slipped and so anyway drew caught
it we won the game and after the game me
an AP writer just said to me what were
you thinking about when you threw the
ball and I said I closed my eyes and
said a Hail Mary I was a carefully kid
from Cincinnati and that's and they said
you know the NFL's recognize that's the
first time it was ever said I keep
saying you know Aaron Rodgers who's a
fantastic football player they have it
now the the the Hail Mary pass or
something when they show some of his
he's had a lot of Hail Mary pass yeah
yeah but but they're not D Hail Mary
pass oh so it really started in 75 and
it's the Catholic kid from Cincinnati I
was I was kind of proud of that the I
think the Blessed Virgin is gonna let oh
I think you're going there Roger yeah
yeah I think I think you've done you've
done pretty well where's your Heisman my
car it's our house I got a little office
and my wife and when she built this
house gave me an office so I have a
little office with the Huysmans in there
yeah so all you she said I'm gonna give
you one room to put all your stuff in
she built this house and I moved in with
her this is you know about 10 years ago
through this this is our you know you
know we got a bunch of kids and
grandkids and so we got a lot of room in
this house but my my office is uh it's a
nice little office and and she she's
been real nice to me
married 53 years now so we're good for
you he's Roger Staubach he's the former
Heisman winner Super Bowl MVP and of
course hall-of-famer are you colorblind
well you know I they called color
ignorant I know all the colors I just
haven't associated the names with them
yet
they know that no there is a but I've
never really totally passed you know
especially the the dot in you know I can
see a you know a number real clear if
it's the right coloring and then
sometimes the wrong coloring I can't so
I've never really passed that test
didn't ever hurt you when you were
playing quarterback well I did blame it
a couple times on interception I'm sure
Tom Landry was you know you look like a
blue jersey the the but but it was a
factor in the service I was I could not
fly or couldn't go Navy line and so I
was a logistics supply officer and you
know I was proud to be a naval naval
officer but that bike being being
partially truly partially colorblind
because I it's not an obvious thing when
I look at colors but like like green and
white light green and white at a
distance I mean I get it's so so yes I'm
partially colorblind if you were coming
out of high school now would how
attractive would the Naval Academy be
with that would you have still gone
there or do you think I think yeah I
think it's I think it's more attractive
it's a great school it's got its got you
know when we graduated we all have
graduated with a Bachelor of Science and
Engineering which is a BS and that's
pretty much what I have an engineering
is a so so today there's a lot more
academically majors that you could have
and it's a great school and in you know
the service is something I'm very proud
of I'm really proud of those that stayed
in the service longer than me and and
then in you know during the Vietnam era
I was I was in Vietnam I was supporting
the Marine Corps and the in Danang in
July with a Naval Support Group and so I
wasn't out there getting getting shot at
like like these guys so I have a
tremendous amount of respect for the
military and I'm proud to be a part of
it and it was you know a limited period
of time but I'm
you know like that's why I'm appalled
with USAA with the salute the services
to honor in our military and you know
this year we're honoring through action
and we're hoping that the 20 million
veterans out there that that we really
pick pick out a veteran and honor them
and you can even put a V on your your
hand and take a picture of it to show
that you're honoring a veteran so this
is this is a you know special to me in
my life as was being in the service and
you can do a hashtag honor through
action more information can be found at
us a.com slash Veterans Day I saw where
Troy Aikman was pretty critical of the
Cowboys said do you pretty much need to
start over again with this team what do
you think of the Cowboys situation right
now Roger well I I I feel that it's a
it's a combination of a few things on
offense I I do believe that dak Prescott
said leader I think he's a good really
good quarterback and he's gonna continue
to to show that and they got a great
runner in think that they're their
offensive line it's been a lot of
injuries on defense Sean Lee is out
again and they've they've really gotten
themselves in trouble I think with some
injuries and things so so it's been a
difficult year and they're the receivers
they got a new one with this you know
Mari Cooper which is going to help I
think a lot and he so we really didn't
have the key key wide receiver so it
it's a team missing a few pieces you
know and I'm a big fan of Troy I think
you know actually was the best I mean he
he looked looks at it does they need a
bigger bigger picture a bigger plan I I
think there's just some pieces here and
there that if they get them together and
especially get to get some of the guys
back that are hurt on defense and and
same with the offensive line that
they'll be back in action again but you
know hopefully it's not going to be too
late this this game against
Philadelphia's you know it if we can
beat the Eagles
they'll be back in action again at least
there'll be some hope if we don't and
it's it's not gonna be a Huckabee for
the rest of the year you think Jason
Garrett is I mean I I wonder here if we
see what we see is what he is and that
you know you need a coaching change yeah
well I you know I like Jason but I you
know I don't I'm not privy to the
meetings and how things were organized
and the things that I if I had more
territorial to really what's going on
internally I I am NOT so the only thing
I know about Jason is mostly social here
in Dallas he'll do anything for anybody
is his wife Burrell as as good as it
gets to they they're a great her great
asset a lot of good things happening but
but in the locker room you know that's
that's you know Troy knows that better
than I do
yeah you just look at this situation and
I do like Jason Garrett it's impossible
not to like him I but I don't know who's
more of it I think Jerry being the GM
Jerry being the owner is one thing but
Jerry being the GM I just don't think
you can do that in today's NFL world
well yeah and you know in Jason you know
being a good guys and enough in the NFL
you got it you got to make sure you win
football games and so there's been a you
know we had a thirteen and three year a
few years ago but we're uh we're
definitely uh III do I think it's the
lot of it is they're gonna keep some key
elements on defense and offense that's
the offensive line and with the injuries
I think it's really really hurt the
house this year but you can't can't make
excuse I guess on on just injuries but
I'd like to see Jason get a turnaround
this year because he is a likable guy
and that's where I run into him a lot is
the good things he does here in Dallas
for people for more information on what
Rogers talking about with the salute to
service award presented by USAA it's a
hashtag honor through action more
information can be found at us
come slash Veterans Day always great to
talk to you Roger we do appreciate your
time thanks for joining us
okay Dan take care no Roger Saban he was
crushing it where's your Heisman on the
hood of my car for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]